and you can expect more traffic near the
Las Vegas Convention Center as well as
thousands arrive for the National
Association of broadcasters show this
week it's one of the biggest conventions
we see here locally every year 8 News
now's Madison Kimbrough is live tonight
with what attendees are saying Madison
yeah Sasha those I spoke to really
excited to be back for another year many
sharing at the airport was jam-packed as
tens of thousands of people are expected
to attend this convention this week
I feel like I've seen a lot more people
it's still not quite pre-2020 levels but
I would say it's definitely an increase
from last year there's really good
enthusiasm Matt Livingston and his wife
are here for this year's National
Association of broadcasters conference
at the Las Vegas Convention Center
Livingston from Austin Texas is pleased
that NAB is here in Vegas as he plans on
taking full advantage of all our city
has to offer I'm going to see one or two
shows this week I'm going to take a
client out to a nice dinner I'm going to
do a handful of cab rides you know I'm
definitely going to put money in Uber's
pocket a bunch of restaurants Pockets
the NAB conference known for showcasing
the newest in technology within the
broadcasting field brought just over 50
000 attendees last year with the
expectation of it being even bigger this
year well last year was the first in two
years since the covid epidemic and it
was really cool because all of us
industry people had been away and so it
was the energy of the convention was
really neat and it was kind of fun and
this year is really much the same and
for some International Traveler Not only
was it their first time attending the
conference but also their first time in
Vegas too I travel long hours to get
here we're here to learn and to absorb
and to see what trends are currently
happening I'm looking forward to
exploring that spot it will be work and
play definitely
this convention will last until Thursday
with the next one set for the beginning
of May and it's going to be the online
retail sourcing Expo like I said that's
the beginning of the first week of May
reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now